[Musique]
une vapeur
d'amour la faveur d'un
Destour deux ou trois mots
habiles un rythme
difficile on te parle en syc
en litr en
argot on ouvre les
[Musique]
menotteson pour aimer la
samba descendu des
ces il faut AER la
LI de
métal pour
aimer il faut tendre sa
peau s'ans servir de
Pango sur le rythme
[Musique]
vital Brésil tu te
caches creux de tes sain
va Brésil tu nous
craches la mort de
marigel les vautours de
Rio planqué dans les
[Musique]
buildings surveille les
bidons qui narque vos
[Musique]
usines pendant que nos
guitares ne font que du
[Musique]
pognon Brésil au mal de
cuivre chante
[Musique]
révolution petit bourgeois
d'Europe aux multiples
actions fait gaff
àoxite si le Brésil s'explique
[Musique]
cependant dans nos
pas on adore la
bossa des dames très très
chiques trouve ça
érotique petit bourgeois d'Europe g g
gang aux multiples actions
fais gaffe à ta
[Musique]
boxite si le
Brésil
[Musique]
s'excite
o
vasilero
[Musique]
saaci